yeah um what kind of anxiety like how
was it just could you not function was
it hard was it always was it just always
present it was um in middle school I if
I talked to Middle School
I would blush and turn bright red
enough where the teacher would point it
out and say I remember I had a teacher
appointed out and she goes see how his
face is read in anyone else that would
be an indication that he uh is sick or
having a seizure what you know like so
like yeah I mean it was you know like
there was definitely
some bullying that happened from kids or
adults but
I think I also like that's when I kind
of latched on to Comedy was when we
moved uh then
um but I had an older brother who was
pretty good at sports so I I kind of
hung in on Sports but
I would say you know the reason I
started doing stand up
when I moved to New York I got a job in
advertising as an account guy and the
guy who uh
and in those settings I would get really
nervous and flustered when I would speak
and so if someone suggested I take
improv and so I took Improv
to deal with some of this public
speaking anxiety and then
um someone dared me to do stand-up I
always wanted to do it but again I
didn't know anyone that did it and I
didn't think it was a realistic thing
and so then when I finally
um then I took kind of like a stand-up
seminar it was just you know
um
and I fell in love with it but like I
had stage fright issues I would say for
the first 10 years of my career like
terrified yeah I know I know what that's
like is is it something that you
eventually got on pills to help you meds
was it something that you just
eventually grew out of and just forced
your way out of anxiety or how did you
do it I think some of it was I I think
some of it was just sheer experience
of doing forcing myself to go on stage
but I think some of it was I grew out of
it
I don't think that
I think I it would have helped if I had
medication you know it would have helped
a lot but
um
and then I also I think I did a lot of
uh you know therapy I was in group
therapy in my 20s and
I did some work on my stuff you know my
mother died in my early 20s so like
that's really what prompted me
to not just be compliant and do what I
was told to do right is like when she
died the Injustice of her
death she was 53 I was like well then
you know I don't know what I'm you know
supposed to do so that's when I started
um
you know I I did the improv class then I
started doing stand up and I would do
stand up
uh and then I did acting classes after
work and stand up after that and that
was
uh this uh and I did that for like four
or five
years I mean I was definitely I kept my
day job for a long time but I definitely
resigned myself to be
uh the uncle that lives in a tiny
apartment because I had no success
whatsoever I I thought that I was good
but all my peers all my friends were
they were getting sets on Conan or
Letterman and I was not like they would
just leave the room when I would go on
because they had seen me when I was
really bad so they were like he's not
good so so did you want to quit were the
moment you wanted to quit I didn't want
to quit I just
I had to
come to the realization that
I was not gonna have
a normal success like I was not gonna
have monetary
success